I thought about Al Michaels with the
quarantine that he loves to go to his
you know famous you know restaurant
Toscano and Al joining us on the program
can you do takeout at your restaurant
Dan they closed on January 1st for
remodeling and then we're going to redo
the kitchen and the floor and a few
other things and we're pointed toward a
April first open so here we are the
kitchen is still under construction I
believe a takeout will be available soon
but in the meantime what can I tell you
the Domino's truck knows where we live
and that's that's about the story and
then at the great Linda Michaels who
cooked a lot when we were first married
many moons ago is back in the kitchen
back in the kitchen with Dinah
and here we are so right now my weight
is very very steady at this point I'm
very happy because I'm going out and
walking about eight miles a day so I'm
training for the Olympic race walking a
competition in 2021 or whenever whenever
we're gonna have it but you know what
Dan I wake up this morning and I'm
thinking to myself a number one I woke
up a little early because I had to be on
with you obviously out here on the west
coast so for you I will do anything
thank you but I keep thinking that it's
Groundhog Day I wake up and I'm going
damn it's the same day and how many days
in a row now and it's kind of the point
Dan where I don't know whether it's
April or July or November or 2023 it's
all the same it runs together and that's
what I want you might what am i watching
I'll tell you what so obviously like
everybody else in the country I went to
Tiger King and I loved it
it was unreal then I watched MEK
millions on HBO I guess it is or
underwear one of the mates B or Netflix
yeah
and watch that and you know after Tiger
king it was hard to sit through all of
it because nothing's as good as tiger
King at this particular point but it was
it was fine lasted till the end and that
was
watched a couple of Larry David episodes
oh and then I'll tell you what I did I
hadn't seen it since it came out in 94
95
I watched Pulp Fiction and you know you
forget if you haven't seen a movie in 25
years some of the incredible scenes
there are the script the dialogue wasn't
reacting so I watched that but I'll tell
you what I do every morning I wake up
and just for a little pick-me-up and to
make me feel a little bit better and I
mentioned this to a Mike Tirico on the
show the other day so this is not
breaking news but I wake up and I go to
youtube and if I'm not looking for you
what I will do is I will search Don
Rickles and there must be a hundred to
150 Don Rickles skits with Carson
Letterman Leno camel with Donny and
Marie believe it or not he's on the
Donny and Marie show and I watch that
for about a half hour and as the doctors
will tell you and I don't know whether
it's Doc Rivers or Doctor Zhivago or dr.
Jay but the doctors will tell you that
you that laughter
dilates your vessels your blood vessels
and your arteries so what's better than
that dance so my my suggestions to all
of them the Dan that's and all of the
Dan that audience is to type in Don
Rickles when we get off the phone here
and and enjoy yourself for a half an
hour any sports that you're watching you
know there's nothing to watch but so the
irony is I go to the NFL Network the
other day and I can't watch myself
because I've done those games and it's I
just can't sit there and and watch it
again and I'm too critical of myself but
I'm doing the Super Bowl with Chris I
think it was Philly New England I think
that was the game and then this one with
John Madden Pittsburgh Arizona and I go
over to the NHL Network and they're
playing the movie miracle and then I go
and then I then I go to MLB Network and
I'm doing the game 7 of the 88 player
Dodgers and and these are good problems
to have al but here's the thing and you
know what as well as I so one of my
great friends is is Tom Warner who own
Red Sox and he and Marcy Carsey formed
the kharsa Warner production company and
they did The Cosby Show in the Roseanne
show and you know a times a great guy so
we're walking through the neighborhood
the other day and Marcy Carsey lives a
couple of blocks away so he we decide
that we're gonna call her to see if she
wants to come out and walk with us so
she'd already walk but she comes to the
the front gate and we're standing
several feet apart and she says what are
you up to I said well I don't know what
I'm up to nothing but I'm on television
more than anybody in history and I said
I don't see one residual or one royalty
and Marcy I said Marcy I'm standing by
the mailbox I said can I open this up
and see how many residuals you got today
so anyway Dan that's where I am how you
doing I'm doing well you know I feel
fortunate that we get to do this
you know fritzy's at home McLovin x' at
home Seaton's at home but Paulie and I
are here and in a very scaled-down crew
but I talked to Hank Aaron this week
Jack Nicholas this week Jim Nantz this
week you this week I mean it we're
trying to do whatever normal is we're
trying to do it so I I feel lucky I do I
feel very lucky here yeah I mean we're
doing things I mean think about this the
other you know face time is great so I'm
totally into that now you know you used
to call people audio only and now it's
just a FaceTime I didn't realize how
simple it was and believe it or not you
ready who was on FaceTime or man Bob
Costas whoa Whitney's got a flip phone
no he does but you know Bob Costas who
very recently had a rotary dial phone
and then he went to it was on a party
wine then he went to a flip phone and
apparently I think Jill
Costas got him I think an iPhone Wow I
figured what would the chances I would
call Costas and get him on FaceTime and
everyone with you know unshaven and the
whole thing and looking like a bum like
all of us are looking right now but Bob
has come into the 21st century with it
Wow that's incredible we're talking now
Michael's NBC Sunday Night Football
play-by-play boys how close did you come
to get
traded to ESPN I arias about that oh the
only thing I knew is that Andrew Marsh
and had great sources and kept writing
about it and when Andrew called me I
said hey listen I'm reading you to do
fine that was happening so it never came
to me apparently there was some
discussion as to whether or not I could
be released from my contract and that
was the end of it but everything I knew
came from Andrew trust me but you've
already been traded once so we can't go
boy they al can get traded well you know
part of that deal back in Oh 506 we
through we through in and believe me was
a throw on the deal was already done but
at the end of the day you know we threw
in the Oswald the rabbit nobody knew who
that was but the Disney family wanted to
get the rights through it back so we
threw that in and it was we laughed
about it and the press didn't think that
anything nefarious or insidious was
going on behind the scenes so now you
know I guess if I had gone back maybe I
would have taken Oswald back with me I
also saw a quote from you I think that
had to do with Brady when he came into
one of those pregame meetings with with
the crew from Sunday Night Football and
I'm paraphrasing I think he said you
know I'm the most unhappy eighth-note
quarterback and the NFL is that do I
have that right and that's last year
you're doing it was last November you
know the interesting thing is so in that
meeting we have our regular unit
production crew with Chris and Michonne
and our production folks and the so we
said that on the air that night so this
was in Baltimore they came in they were
the Patriots for eight No
so they're undefeated halfway through
the season they're gonna go up against
Lamar Jackson and he winds up beating
them and at that point the Patriots were
averaging on defense giving up I think
single digits it was eight or nine
points a game but they were on a record
pace and Brady comes in to the meeting
and he basically says at one point I'm
the most unhappy 8no quarterback in
football so what we were trying to do
the forensics under figuring out what's
that all about is it all about the fact
that you know he is going to be a free
agent and knows he's going to leave is
it about the
that the offense is not very good with
the defense is terrific and just going
back to opening day we had the Patriots
against the Steelers in the opening
Sunday night game last year and Brady
walked into the meeting and said he's
very very excited because the defense I
think he said is the best he's ever seen
since he was in New England so he was
right about that the defense was
fantastic up until that point in the
season the offense wasn't very good but
I said to him and you know these you
know I know I'm not going to get be
answer at that point I don't even know
if he knows the answer but they said Tom
I said I can't imagine you can't imagine
you ever playing in another uniform so
I'm gonna lay odds of 43,000 to one that
you will never be in another uniform and
he kind of laughs we all laughed he
walks out of the room and Andy Freeland
who was one of our great research people
and he plunks down two dollars on the
table and says I'll take that bet so I'm
trying to give the two bucks back to
Andy but he won't take it so now I mean
I'm I'm down for eighty-six thousand
dollars this season Dan and if Andy
thinks he's gonna get paid in one lump
sum no way that's gonna be quite the
installment plan but he won the bet how
surprised were you that Brady decided to
walk away very I just didn't see it
happening look Bob Kraft has made it
very clear through the years how much he
loves him treats him like a son wanted
to keep him obviously and we all know
now that you know Tom went to Bob crafts
house and they had a good cry about this
whole thing I just didn't see him
leaving I couldn't I just couldn't
imagine it I mean look Tom is in a place
that nobody's been that I can you know I
George Blanda was different I mean he
played in to his 40s but he was mainly
kicking and you know he he'd played
quarterback a little bit at that
particular point but nobody's been where
Brady's been right now how much longer
does he have to go can he go two more
years three more years whatever it would
be I think Tommy Tom feels great
obviously at this point but I just I
couldn't see it I couldn't see him
walking out the door but but here we are
and you know he needed a little bit of
fresh air and I think when Bob Kraft
said in the interview
after he left that you know sometimes
you have this to this great marriage but
a mother-in-law or father and more
somebody else comes into the picture we
call read between the lines with that
man so you know you can't diminish what
Brady and Belichick did as a pair that
was fantastic and they think in the time
on Howard Stern the other day was
talking about you know people make too
much of the fact though there was
friction or whatever yeah you work with
somebody for 20 years is going to be
friction but look that what they did was
spectacular it was amazing
six Super Bowl wins nine Super Bowl
appearances always in the race but you
know sometimes maybe you need a little
bit of fresh air so Tom goes down to
Florida for that fresh air roughly if
the Gulf of Mexico he's Al Michaels NBC
Sunday Night Football and of course a
couple of minutes ago he talked about
Bob Costas not being a technical whiz
savvy I think he and I as long as I've
known Bobby had a flip phone but
apparently he is able to FaceTime Al
Michaels
yes Paulie Bob Costas unwinding hey Bob
hey welcome hello Dan hello alfalfa that
was an accident
I called Al and I hit some button
inadvertently images and all of a sudden
I saw myself 10-day growth of beard and
there was alfalfa some weird angle from
like underneath his coffee table and it
was all very like George Jetson to me
you know it's very disconcerting
wrapping what are you doing up at this
hour you every time that you run a road
with us Bob Costas would be the guy
you'd walk by his room at the hotel and
the Do Not Disturb sign was out at 1:30
in the afternoon back to bed Bob do you
remember the first time you work with Al
the first time we actually worked
together this has to be a setup before
we ever did anything together on NBC the
first thing was bass ketball in 1998
well I'm in the movie with you I didn't
know that's the first time you guys I
watched that the other night for the
first time Bob yeah I never watched it
all the way through I was like it like
that and plus you can't watch it with
you know the kids so I'm going oh boy
but
yeah you guys were quite a quite a pair
they're quite a tandem you know we
didn't see I will attest this we didn't
see you we didn't see Reggie Jackson we
didn't see Kareem we didn't see Robert
Vaughn or Yasmine Bleeth or Ernest
Borgnine none of the people last night
of shooting it was just the two of us it
started out as a lark and then when they
broke and we started to look at some of
the dailies al looks at me and says what
have we done mm-hmm we've entered our
career but you know what it was out in
retrospect it's like Pootie Tang I
proudly started you think it's a
disaster but then as time goes by it
takes on a certain classic of
appreciation who do you realize that
inadvertently you did a good thing but
the deal is this abandoned Bob I don't
know if you heard the fact that I was
talking about you know Marcy Carsey and
she and Tom Werner you know getting like
18 gazillion dollars worth of residuals
and we get nothing we get nothing for
appearing on MLB Network and NFL Network
and ESPN Classic but we do get residuals
from that and baby that you know that
that's that's a joy you get to the
mailbox every couple of months and
here's a here's a residual from bass
ketball and it's a dollar and 63 cents
after-tax no no Bob before I let both
you guys go what do you watch now I'm
watching some MLB Network the classic
games you know they've responded pretty
quickly Al Kaline passed away the other
day and they showed game 6 and 7 of the
1968 World Series the only world series
that he's played in I check
I checked the NBA Network Chris
Collinsworth so football life was on the
NFL Network the other day I hadn't seen
that before maybe it was the first run
and then I'm watching a lot of news and
I'm reading not just newspapers or stuff
online I'm actually getting to a lot of
books that are on the Shelf that I
hadn't gotten to before that's great
great to talk to both you guys and hope
you're well look forward to actually
hearing you know new games from you al
since all of your you know archival
games are bothering you for Al and he
turns on the baseball Network he's got a
game the NFL Network he's got a game
boohoo
and then the NBA NBA networkers and I
are doing the game with Derek Fisher hey
Dan do we get residuals for this yes you
do
ok yes you do you're gonna get $8 each
yes $8.00 baba baba razor hey listen io
NE Freeland eighty-six thousand so
whatever you want to be I'm happy thank
you guys great to talk to you Bob Costas
Al Michaels